hello and a very warm welcome to this
latest edition of talking Germany and my
guest today is a woman who one day
apparently by chance made the shocking
discovery that her grandfather was a
murderous Nazi war criminal in fact the
notorious concentration camp commandant
Arman Gert familiar to very many people
from Steven Spielberg's movie
Schindler's List now that woman is
Jennifer tiga and I want to say thank
you very much Jennifer - coming to
Berlin today to be here with us on
talking Germany and to share your
remarkable story with us I'd like to
begin with a quote it's a quote from you
you said on the one hand I've had a
completely normal life
and it strikes me that in that sentence
the very interesting words are on the
one hand what do you say well when I I
was brought up as a child in a foster
family first and then I was adopted so I
had many years my childhood that that
one could say normal I was not in
contact with my biological family and
they found out only recently all the
things about my mother my grandmother
and my grandfather that's so disturbing
for me yeah and we're gonna be telling
the whole story and it is a fascinating
story the interesting things that I
indicated in my introduction was that
there was a there was a major change in
your life when you went into a a library
in your in town of Hamburg where you
live and by pure chance you stumbled
across a book that changed your life
we'll talk about the book in a second
but I'm very interested in the in the
incident itself you were drawn to this
book do you really believe it was by
chance good not so I'm not sure I just
explained you how it was today it was a
day it's now five years ago and it was a
it was a sunny day completely normal day
in August so went to this library in the
library is not a small library but it's
a big library like the Central Library I
live in in Germany in Hamburg I must
interrupt you because I actually I
became very interested in this and I
phoned the library to ask them how many
books they have they have three hundred
and fifty thousand books
what changed your life yeah so I don't
know till today I have no real
explanation I just know I went to the
library and I was there I was already
there for a while I was not searching
for a specific book the sisters
strolling around and suddenly I saw this
book it was on the shelf and it had a
red cover so it took I grabbed at the
book and I quickly went through the book
first I had a look at the cover and
there was a small photograph under on
the left side and it showed the picture
of a woman an elderly woman may be
around her forties something like this
and she had a she looked familiar
perfectly familiar not really it's like
someone I knew there was just something
in her eyes that made me I don't know
wonder so I took the book and I went
through the book mmm and there were more
photographs and there was text and just
went through the pages in in the very
end there was a summarization and I
could read biographical details and
these details I knew from the paperwork
surrounding from my adoption so when I
when I saw this somehow I don't know
what happens in the brain I am NOT a
brain specialist but it became clear to
me this must be a book a very special
book and it was a book about my
biological family that I haven't seen of
my mother I haven't seen for many many
many years and no one told me it's such
a remarkable story okay you've had your
first impressions there from Jennifer
tiga and we've heard just a little bit
of the story of how her life was changed
as the cliche goes right out of the blue
here's a fuller version of that story
before we talk again
Jennifer we've already had a sense of
how your life is it is a real sort of
overlapping of ordinary and
extraordinary and just to get a feel for
that I'd like to go back to the the
occasion when you took the book off of
the shelf and you realized your life had
changed just three days later you were
with your son at his first day at school
you know a very ordinary everyday
occasion how do you bring those to the
emotions together that are evoked by
those two different occasions it was
almost impossible there was another
incident before when I found the book
the same day I went home and I was on my
bed I was reading the book
cover-to-cover one like in three or four
hours it took me and then I went to the
Internet and I started to research
because I wasn't sure whether what I had
read written I read in the book was true
so I needed to verify and while doing
the research I found a note that the
same day there was in German TV a movie
a movie about my mother and the the the
servant of my grandfather was living in
the house and pleasure Helen was
inspired also featured in the movie so
this was the same day and the evening I
was sitting on the couch watching this
movie and I saw how the that was
everything I could see where my mother
was living now I could see how my
grandfather was executed so this was so
serial it was so so strange that
experience it's experiencing all this
and having a day all day life like going
with my my my my parents-in-law
and my son to a restaurant because we
needed to celebrate was yeah was almost
impossible but I managed to do
and this is all because I mean the the
real challenge for you is it's not just
it's your story of course but it's also
the story of other people so very close
to you in your life like your
grandmother tell us a little bit more
about her because she seems to be an
incredibly complex character
she's very complex and she was she's a
person who was my childhood someone I
knew so when I found out about my
grandfather this was of course something
very distressing but the thing that
disturbed me more was the figure of my
grandfather the grandmother I told you
before that I was was adopted and the
circumstances in my childhood but not so
let's say this way it wasn't a safe
surrounding for children
my mother was together with the with a
man who did beat her and so my
grandmother was a a woman for me who
provided me with the safe surrounding
and she was someone who not only liked
me but who when I came and she opened
the door there was a smile on her face
and on my face so this is what I could
remember of my grandmother and when I
read the book and I found out all the
other things and suddenly got to know a
different side of her it was not know
that I didn't know before so this almost
yeah also impossible to deal with this
and it took me a long time somehow to
find a solution how to how to integrate
this into my life and one way that you
did that was actually by visiting the
concentration camp which is effectively
in a suburb of Krakow in Poland in
Poland well how did that help you the
concentration camp is not existing
anymore
there's only a place we can can remember
when I went there I went there not to it
wasn't it wasn't my idea to go there to
visit the place to see the place more
important was for me I needed to find a
way to with over a new then somehow to
continue to live my life and I always
thought when I just I couldn't Esther
granddaughter of I'm on good I couldn't
say okay this is something that was in
the past it doesn't affect me and of
course it affected me but I needed to
leave the past behind I needed to to
look forward so when I went to Prague ow
and I went there not to visit but I
wanted to put flowers too to leave
flowers there it was for me one could
describe it or compare it when you visit
or when you go to a funeral because you
need to say goodbye and sometimes you
need to say it in a way that is
something that is I don't know probably
you know what I mean you don't have to
go to a funeral you can say you can do
it also privately but is this a ritual
it's something yes it's symbolic moment
for you deeply personally a very
important symbol yeah a moment of
closure yeah I think yep and I didn't
know it in advance I didn't know why I
felt so important for me to to go to
crack up but when I when I left there
was my flight back I felt a great sense
of relief okay a little bit more just a
second before we continue let's have a
look at two scenes from the movie
Schindler's List and we begin with the
scene that brings together Oskar
Schindler and his accountant it's
actually
who had a profound influence of course
on Schindler
shocking scenes the the word that is
conventionally used to describe somebody
like our mom Gert is evil very many
people would use that word to explain
his pathology his behavior is that oh is
that a term that you would use as well
that you is that an explanation for what
happened I think there's a lot of Eva in
my grandfather but I don't think that
evil exists like the pure evil I think
when you look at people everyone was
born but the it was born blank so people
become the way they are but many
influences and my grandfather was of
course someone who was especially
through the film a symbol of evil but
mankind is not you can't divide mankind
and evil and good with my grandfather
it's quite easy because there's so much
evil one can see with my grandmother
because you asked me about her before
it's less it's less it's less obvious
because she had different sides she was
she was not killing herself but she was
closing her eyes so she here you can see
there's evil and there is some good she
did some good things as well with me
also there was an extraordinary mixture
of things because she she she was
perhaps an opportunist who profited from
Armand Gertz status in the Nazi time at
the same time though in the in the
post-war period for example I know that
she was she was an admirer of Villa
Brandt the social democrat Chancellor
she had sort of she had liberal
sentiments in her how do you explain
that I don't really know it's also
striking because my father is Nigerian
and my father was a friend of someone
who was living with my grandmother she
was she had someone who was renting out
in a room in her apartment if she needed
bubbly
to share the apartment because she
needed the money money at this time was
extraordinary as well for this yeah for
this time my father with dark-skinned me
was thinking that my mother my
grandmother must have been a racist this
is the this does not really fit and she
was also she also had someone living in
the household who was homosexual at this
time it was not only forbidden it was
something you could go to jail yeah it
was in the in the 1917 so she in her
personality you see and how how people
are they have good sites and they have
bad sides and with my grandfather I
think the bad sides they're so obvious
that yeah there is some either but I
think he's he's maybe one could also
define him as a psychopath another
extraordinary aspect of the whole story
you're telling is that you saw the film
Schindler's List the first time now I
don't know how many times you've seen
the movie maybe you only saw it once I
just don't know but the first time you
saw it in in Israel and you had gone as
a young student to actually study in
Israel how do you fit that into this
whole complex that is your story to
question the first thing many people
assume that I've seen the movie a lot of
times I saw the movie and I saw the
movie not once I saw it a few times but
still it is a movie but it's important
for me are all the historical sources
and I know them and I know a lot of lot
is true so this is what counts for me
more so I saw the movie but ok I don't
have to see it 10 times
I saw the movie the first time when I
was living in Israel and I was a student
I was in Israel I came to Israel in the
beginning of my twenties I was in Paris
before and there I met a girl from
Israel who invited me to come over for
holidays so I went there and stayed for
five years but this is a different story
but when I was there I saw the movie in
the in the Israeli television
and for me it was I think the same as it
was for everyone it was a it was touchy
and but it was something I thought I'm
not connected with why should I
it was so far from from something when I
could imagine that I did not that I did
not make a make a make a connect maybe I
did not make made it make it made a
connection something
it's yep bringing the bringing all this
and that all of this together worth it
with your visit to Israel your long
visit to Israel the fact that you're
very familiar with that society you also
as far as I understand you you went on a
visit with his Raley schoolchildren to
the to the camp near Krakow to what
remains of the camp what how did they
deal with that and how did you deal with
them and the whole question of guilt
first of all I was not sure whether I
should do this trip because I said it
once I'm not a specialist on the
Holocaust so I thought if I go there
maybe they expect me they expect someone
else and I can't fulfill the expectation
but my my friend annatee she asked me
and it was the class of her son and
normally they are also accompanied by
their parents so she went with the class
and I decided okay this time it's a good
idea I would go with the class it was a
very emotional trip I think for both of
us for all the the students and for me
it was the same day my adopted father
died so I came straight from the
hospital and I went to meet up with the
children it was I was not prepared first
I thought I will do the introduction in
Hebrew and I had no time to prepare
something but still we were
very close and I told them who I am and
I asked them or I told them if you want
you can ask me whatever you like I will
try to explain unit will try to answer
you the questions and this is what they
did so we had a wonderful wonderful
encounter one could say and yeah in the
end we we we were standing in front of
big man Memorial and they asked me and
I'd like to hit flowers and this time I
was not alone but I was with my with my
friends and they asked me whether I'd
like to put the flowers for them and I
did so I wasn't sure in the beginning
also with this when I am the right
person but because they asked me I did
so and it felt yeah I thought good good
for you good for you yeah all right and
it felt right good and right yep or one
aspect of life here in Germany in recent
decades has been that many of the people
who lived through the war years
including victims and perpetrators of
terrible crimes like the ones we've been
talking about have for many different
reasons being unable to talk about their
experiences we have this report on how
important it is to share those difficult
memories
Jennifer Germany has a very difficult
recent history that's no doubt about
that and some people confront it and
some people are in denial about its
recent history there has been a tendency
to view Germany as a society that is
scarred that is haunted by the untold
stories is that how you experience
Germany as you were growing up is that
how you experience Germany now perhaps
haunted is not the word that I would use
I was born in 1970 so when I went to
school in history class we did talk
about the Holocaust we did talk about
the world war did talk so much about
this subject that we did not even talk
about the time after the Second World
War so we never talked about the United
Nations or something it was really
really a big issue in my school but it
was only on an academic level people
were not talking about their own in for
example like in my in my family I can
only relate to my adopted family my
adopts its brand father he was in Africa
and Arama
and we talked about it but I I don't
know maybe I felt some kind of I thought
it's not I did not want to bother him
you know to ask more know what was
really happening in the war did you kill
someone or like these this kind of
question that that you feel
uncomfortable you know when you're
supposed to answer so I didn't want to
make him feel guilty or that's
interesting that's your adoptive father
and obviously a very sensitive
relationship let's talk about your
actual biological mother since you made
the discovery about your about your own
personal story you have met your your
biological mother tell us what happened
there I met her
met her after I found that the book I
had a lot of questions questions about
the history but also questions about our
relationship and there's a blank spot in
the year 1970 when I was born so I
wanted to meet her and we have to find
answers to all these questions that were
Monte when we met it took me 1 and 1/2
years of preparation because there were
so many difficult feelings that I needed
first somehow to had to put everything
into place and also to see her not only
as my mother but as the woman she's also
a woman with who is now an elderly woman
with a with her own biography and she
was brought up by my grandmother who
never really told her about her father
so she also grew up with the kind of
family secret and I needed to understand
all this first before I could could meet
her in real life when we met it was a
very very warm in a very nice nice 3-4
hours that we spent together and
fortunate yeah it worked out it worked
out I thought that we would see each
other more often but I think she needs
some time so at the moment yeah one and
a half years ago mm-hmm another moment
she doesn't want to see you and I was
said this way my door is open if she
wants to step in she's more than welcome
yeah but you can't force someone it's
her decision and I respect her decision
but I hope to have more contact
when you were younger you suffered from
depression could you just in a nutshell
explain how it felt
yeah it felt it feels for me at least
felt I had no contact with my inner self
and I felt tired and I felt full of
questions in my hat with no answer ok
we'll talk about the symptoms and the
possible answers in just a second but
it's not just in Germany but around the
world depression is seen as an
increasingly widespread disorder
it's a complaint that can have a huge
impact on people's day-to-day lives as
we've seen with Jennifer and it's
certainly not easy to treat our next
report features a woman who has written
a book about her experience with
combating depression
Jennifer tiga the Ida the woman in that
report says that she won her battle
against depression does it have to be a
battle that you have to win to overcome
depression yes little think so in your
case I had the feeling that when you
described your depression and in your
book what what you what you're
describing is a is like a jigsaw that's
yourself it's your own story and one or
two pieces are missing I think there
were more pieces missing than just one
or two just explained it once when you
make a puzzle I do like doing puzzles
myself so I start with the frame and
then you put in the pieces and in my
life it was the frame was missing so
when I found the book I had the frame
and then I could put in all the small
pieces it became a whole picture and in
life I don't think that oh at least it
would be a nice idea but it does life is
not like this probably I won't have all
the pieces in the end but at least they
can see the whole picture now and this
is a big big big relief and it's a big
difference to how I felt before I know
some people have suggested that the
process for you of writing the book the
intention of writing the book was a sort
of therapy that's the way some people
have interpreted that are they are they
right to do so absolutely wrong the book
that's chapter with my grandmother this
is the chapter it is very personal
because I had not the answers before I
wrote the book and you see a development
in this chapter but it is a book that I
wrote because I thought there's so many
issues the issue of identity the issue
of guilt this year of self-esteem what
does it make with the child when it's
given up at such an early age of its
life and all these things I wanted to
share with people and I hope I mean I
don't know but I hope that a lot of
people can relate to this and that it
gives them and you
do you hope they look to think do you
hope that people can relate to the book
or do you know because I know that
people can because in the last couple of
weeks while I've been working around the
book because I knew I was going to be
meeting you
I spoke to so many people who said yes
the book the story they've helped me it
was when I wrote the book but now all
what I what I received may of letters
phone calls yes people do start to think
and what I want is that it's not an book
you know that only has they did of
course the past is important but you
need to look look ahead and the final
word of the book is the in Hebrew it's
tikva antique fermions in english hope
one last question
all that we've been talking about is
concerned with how your story was told
to you yeah how has that influenced how
you will tell the story to your children
yes
isn't when they've reached the right age
I already told my children but I told
them not everything because all the
sadistic details and how you know people
were killed with gas or how the dogs
were killing people this is something
you should need to share with your
children in in this age they're quite
small but they do know most of the
things that of course they know about
that I know about their biological
family my family and I think it will
give them a strong feeling of identity
and they won't have to deal with the
toxic power that this family secret can
have and now with the book hopefully in
ten years they were not ten years maybe
five years they were read it and then
they have the whole answer thank you one
quick question we always have a quiz at
the end of the show and I didn't want to
have a quiz today I just wanted to ask
you one question which always strikes me
is so important do we learn from history
or do we continue making the same
mistakes
I hope we learn from history but reality
shows that we still have to learn a lot
and we're doing the misstates over and
over and over again and you are helping
us an awful lot to try and avoid doing
just that what a remarkable life
jennifer tiga thank you very much once
again for sharing it with us there's
more talking Germany and my blog on an
hour archived on our website if you've
enjoyed today's show as much as I have
come back next week bye bye until June
you